on est dans la pleine période des phases
de lancement de produit je vous ai parlé
de pas mal de smartphones fait
continuelle faire une marque dont je
vous ai déjà parlé qui vient de lancer
un tout nouveau produit à l'instant
c'est celui là c'est le rytme 6 alors
avant tout vous dire sur le rythme et 6
pas si vous souvenez quelques jours je
vous ai dit pendant confinement peut
m'envoyer toutes vos vidéos de
confinement mais dire comment ça se
passait chez vous et cetera et cetera et
cetera à l'iml qui apparaît juste en bas
et au bâton sans regarder tout de suite
la vidéo du jour
moi je me alix y pense du coup voilà on
en parlait de confinement du coup on se
dit versier comme on peut soit de jouer
à la console soit joder de la télé chez
moi mon quotidien d'aucune début du
confident merci à toi pour la vidéo
n'oubliez pas l'e-mail et la renvoyer
toutes vos participations comment se
passe le confinement chez vous ce que
vous avez envie de partager si t'arrêtes
s'est arrêté là on pouvait y aller on va
se rencontrer aujourd'hui sur ce
smartphone le rythme ici ce qui vient
tout juste d'être présenté et d'ailleurs
je vous dis tout de suite c'est un
smartphone qui est à gagner pour aider
votre rythme ici c'est très facile vous
avez un lien en bas d'un description
vous avez qu à cliquer et a participé au
delà d'une jolie boîte et de cette jolie
couleur très printanière quels sont les
promesses que vous fait le rythme et 6
est ce qu'il est intéressant qu'est ce
qu'il vaut qu' eric misse vous ne
connaissez pas encore la marque qu'est
ce qu'elle offre comme valeur et surtout
on va se poser la question aux de ces
jolies petites bêtes là c'est leur hymne
ici depuis quelques jours je le teste le
musée de tous les côtés et je le
maintiens donné mon retour
avant toute chose on va commencer par
regarder la boîte on retrouve le logo
bon envoyé hier un bien d'un goût de ce
côté là ça marche quand on louera quand
elle veut bien de retrouver intérieur un
petit message veille
welcome to win mi-femme ils y ont vu
vraiment vous intégrer dans une toute
nouvelle famille à l'intérieur moi aussi
j'ai une petite coque de protection
normalement le smartphone est là dans
cette petite pochette mais moi je vais
enlever vous enlevez cette partie là et
vous retrouvez votre bloc de charges
alors moi j'ai pas un bloc de charge
français néanmoins vous vous aurez votre
blog de charge français vous pouvez être
rassurés les cycles de charge et en usb
c est en usb à deux côtés voyez il ya
rien de garde un goût mais ça fait le
boulot parce que le plus intéressant se
situe
ici la vraie valeur c'est le téléphone
vous le voyez alors malheureusement
glatens un petit peu à prendre un peu
trop les traces de doigts et à prendre
un peu la poussière faut donc venir déjà
le protéger pour éviter de l'abîmé et si
vous voulez pas vous retrouver
régulièrement afin de nettoyer surtout
si vous êtes maniacs pourra tout de
suite ce qui vient frapper le regard
c'est qu'on a quatre caméras à l'arrière
alors je vous le dis tout de suite on
est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme
là c'est le comedd bleus vous avez
également un com est blanc avec quelques
petits reflets bon ça il faut
effectivement que vous puissiez vous
l'avoir sauvé pourquoi vous en rendre
compte mais moi je ressasse efficace aux
alain dégrade un peu plus clair un peu
plus foncée ici pour trouver des petites
lille
vous avez le branding readme vous avez
un écran qui est quand même relativement
grand alors là c'est un petit peu caché
par le fond d'écran c'est très très
malin vous avez une caméra qui se
planquent jusque là mais le point noté
c'est surtout que vous avez un menton
qui est quand même assez grand c'est pas
du tout étonnant sur un smartphone à ce
prix l'âge de tout de suite le premier
tarif ses 229 euros 90 c'est tout vous
dire il ya de l'eau des règles
différentes config et ça vous le saurez
à la fin sur un choix intéressant kate a
fait part il me de venir vous dire que
sur ce côté là les retrouver le bouton
pour venir l'allumé pour les tanks qui
fait office également de capteur
d'empreintes digitales mais sinon vous
n'avez absolument rien en dessous vous
avez un petit haut parleur mono
de quoi bien chargé en nuages baisser le
micro une prise jack
tandis que le côté j'ai trouvé votre
bouton pour venir monter baisser le
volume est ici votre tiroir de karting
qui peut accueillir double catane aussi
plus une carte micro sd et sur le dessus
vous devez absolument rien voilà donc un
design assez standard par rapport à ce
qu'on peut en trouver en 2020 dans cette
catégorie de prix on peut le prendre
très facilement à une seule main pour
moi et vu le positionnement tarifaire là
dessus a regardé ici un écran de 6,5
pouces full hd plus de 1400 1080 pixels
à 405 pixels par pouce son écran qui
occupent 90 5% la face avant remy n'a
pas communiqué sa technologie de la
dalle néanmoins je pense qu'ici on se
retrouve avec une jolie dalle lcd mais
surtout ici un écran avec une fréquence
de rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 90
ans
vous le voyez si les paramètres vous
pouvez soit laisser faire le boulot
automatiquement pour qu'il vous
sélectionne le meilleur taux de
rafraîchissement en fonction d'autres
utilisations 90 ans
c'est très bien ça chez nous manque ça
va concerner davantage de batterie il ya
au dessus de savoir sur cet écran c'est
je trouve qu'ils tirent quand même
beaucoup vers le bleu et s'est pas
complètement optimale qu'il faut faire
c'est vous venez dans vos paramètres
vous allez dans affichage et luminosité
pour venir changer directement la
température de couleurs de l'écran
profite de mettre sur plus chaud mais
dans l'absolu le second serait quand
même devenir plutôt active et la case
ici qui s'appelle soins des yeux sur
soins des yeux c'est quand même beaucoup
plus jeunes mais croyez-moi on s'y
habitue très facilement et c'est
vraiment beaucoup mieux pour vos yeux
à noter ici que rémy
me un verre corning gorilla glass 3 pour
multimédia ça fait à fond on retrouve
bien sûr ici le petit point sont alors
on aime on n'aime pas moi je suis pas
extrêmement fans mais bon voilà c'est
comme ça c'est la technologie de 2020
donc on va pas cracher dessus il ya du
sont plutôt pas mal pour que l'eau par
leur kimono ici s'en ressentent quand
même plutôt qualitatif médium bien
évidemment montbard fait aussi des sons
un peu grave donc sa grâce à falcao le
point qu'un terrain c'est que si vous
avez une prise jack pour brancher votre
casque est très facilement et comme il
ya du bluetooth 5.0 vous pouvez
également utiliser un casque sans fil
côté performances on d'un médiatique
avec un avion j'ai 90 t on l'a donc ici
un processeur milieu de gamme de
mediatek plutôt orienté vers le gaming
vous avez 4 ou 8 gigas de ram
lp ddr 4x et vous avez 64 ou 128 go de
stockage en ufs deux points ça fera le
boulot en lecture écriture c'est parce
qu'avoir deux plus rapides mais une fois
de plus on est sur un smartphone milieu
de gamme et nous donne parfaitement ce
qu'on l'attend lui et d'ailleurs à ce
sujet line au score sur un total de 282
6311 ce qui vient de positionner en 28e
position juste en dessous du raid
minutes huit pros et au dessus du
samsung galaxy s 9 on l'a donc des
performances tout ce qui est plus
honorable et pour faire tourner nombre
de jeux ici sa frappe parfaitement le
taf
ici on a une batterie de 4300
milliampères york je trouve assez
endurante une fois de plus d'autonomie
dépend des usages de ce que vous allez
en faire mais si vous êtes sûrs d usage
modéré un jour et nuit votre smartphone
vous aura absolument aucun problème à
noter vous avez un chargeur de 30 watts
de la recharge rapide dans votre boîte
ça c'est bien ça vous permet de
recharger 2-0 à 70 % en seulement 30
minutes et pour une charge complète il
vous faudra une heure autant dire que
globalement ça se passe assez bien au
niveau de l'eau à se retourner si sur
remy ou à y trouve ça pas mal mais c'est
pas complètement dingue c'est parce que
je les préférées et notamment au niveau
des paramètres je trouve pas ça
extrêmement extrêmement lisible
effectivement des icônes sur le côté
avec des petites réparations ça vous
souhaite pas tout de suite aux yeux il
faut venir gratter un peu pour
comprendre comment ça marche néanmoins
une fois vous êtes venu dans venise et
par comprendre et des choses qui me
paraissent un peu bizarre notamment au
niveau de la traduction ici magazine
écran d'accueil et écran de verrouillage
bon ça sera du point de détail et
quelques petites options et moi si vous
faites un appui ici de quelques secondes
eh bien ça vous déclenchez votre google
assistance à vous de retrouver dans
outils pratiques des paramètres au
niveau de la batterie de la sécurité de
bien-être numérique et contrôles
parentaux bon vous comprenez un petit
peu l'histoire moyens tout ce que je
trouvais pas mal à attendre et c'est que
je suis de retrouver et c'est là où je
me perds un petit peu c'est que je
trouve pas facilement où sont les
paramètres notification barre d'état
c'est pas là
un fichage jeu avec la salle et j'ai
retrouvé ses dents magazine écran
d'accueil et écran de verrouillage vous
allez tout en bas et vous pouvez définir
le style des icônes en sorte que vous
retrouvez dans color au s2 au pot vous
pouvez choisir la forme de vos icônes
vous choisissez les coins plus ou moins
arrondis comme vous le souhaitez il
voulait qu'il soit au premier plan ou
pas ça vous a grandi et s'avoue diminue
l'école et puis ensuite l'icône
simplement la taille de l'icône voyez
vous avez pas mal de petits réglages
voilà je trouve ça assez rigolo mais moi
aussi ma version de remy ou a dit
vouloir trouver là c'est la v 1.0 bon je
pense qu'encore un petit peu de boulot
pour venir améliorer tout ça en tout cas
c'est une alternative qui est assez
intéressante et laissez vous le voyez on
tombe sur un android 10 ans tombe bien
évidemment être le plextor google mais
ils ont eux mêmes leurs propres
catalogues d'applications qui s'appelle
l' app market
aujourd'hui sur le marché européen la
remarque est n'est pas là pour venir
concurrencer le plextor de google mais
vous savez ce qui se passe avec le
huawei est assez intéressant et je pense
que ça nourrit des réflexions chez
beaucoup de constructeurs alors je ne
suis pas sûr aujourd'hui que remy
souhaite s'émanciper de google
stratégiquement ça serait une grosse
erreur
mais allez savoir ce qui pourrait se
passer dans les années à venir en tout
cas ce qu'on peut constater tout
simplement ce qu'ils ont eux mêmes leurs
propres était halle d'application vous
avez quatre capteurs photos le tout
premier si c'est un ultra grand-angle de
8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.3 avec un
champ de vision 219 degrés si c'est la
caméra principale de 64 mégapixels et
ouvre à f 1.8 qui avec la technologie ka
pixels en informera de sortir des photos
en 16 mégapixels en dessous vous avez si
une petite caméra de 2 mégapixels qui
est là pour le mode portrait pour les
facebook et c'est une caméra noir et
blanc qui ouvre à f 2.4 et vous avez en
dessous une caméra pour la macro
également une caméra de 2 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 d'esquisser dans sa petite
bulle vous avez une caméra de cette
fille de 16 mégapixels que bref 2.1 pas
prévu que purement logicielle ça fait le
boulot il vraiment tout ce que je veux
dire reproché ici et je trouve que c'est
pas bien réfléchi de la part de rémy
c'est un petit peu dommage c'est
lorsqu'il est passé en ultra grand-angle
à vous le voyez vous avez le foin et
vous avez un petit point à côté
mais lorsque vous venez zoom est comme
ça voyez vous pouvez pas venir dézoomer
pour arriver sur l'ultra grand temps
leur avoue chercher dîner ou est-ce
qu'il est venu très longtemps que je le
trouve pas en fait il faut revenir là il
faut appuyer là tu n'avais donc aucun
moyen intuitif de passer de l'ultra
grand angle au reste il faut appuyer là
par contre une fois vous êtes là voulait
s'appuyer et là vous montez comme vous
voulez jusqu'à un zoom x 10 11 ou
numérique ça demanderait encore être
améliorée d'un point de vue purement
expérience utilisateur ici absolument
aucun zoom optique vous n'avez
absolument aucune stabilisation que ce
soit enfin que ce soit en outre à grand
temps que ce soit en x 2 et au delà on
reste sur un smartphone milieu
donc on va pas venir lui reprocher les
modes après sont assez standard nuit
vidéos photos portrait 64 mégapixels si
vous voulez vraiment sentir des photos
absolument en 64 mégapixels et plus avec
time lapse la macro qui situe la
ralentit pro la mode panorama vous
pouvez bien filmer en full hd en 60 et
30 images par seconde mais par contre en
cas de cas ce sera uniquement en 30
images par secondes quand vous voulez
filmé par contre en vidéo voudrait une
petite stabilisation numérique allait
pas complètement dingue mais là c'est le
boulot on va se garder quelques photos
qui ont été pris avec le readme six sa
série photos qui étaient prises avec la
caméra principale mais voyait le point a
été fait à côté et non pas sur la rose
ultra grand-angle caméra principale
jusqu'aux une fois de sa vague le rendu
est quand même honnête
une fois 5 on prend beaucoup de bruit
c'est pas terrible mais dans le fascisme
ne parlons pas caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle fois deux fois cinq
voiliers faut 5 ça devient lisse et
c'est pas beau il ya du bruit faut 10
c'est vraiment pas terrible
et là on vient faire de la macro alors
si vous regardez vraiment la macro je
trouve que le rendu est pas d'un go on a
beaucoup de bruit il ya vraiment un côté
très lisse et le rendu n'est pas du tout
à l'état tige sur beaucoup de mal à
comprendre pourquoi est ce que les
constructeurs cherchent à nous faire
absolument des caméras macro alors que
le rendu est vraiment pas vos caméras de
celle fille fait plutôt bien le taf
le mode portrait aussi pas mal je trouve
qu'il dit tour vraiment bien si vous
regardez là le contour des doigts est
quand même vachement bien fait pour voir
qu'on n'a pas de caméra d'offres au
niveau des cheveux c'est pareil c'est
pas évident là espère un petit peu mais
bon ça me paraissait normal et le rendu
est assez cali et même là entre les
doigts je suis assez bluffé ça c'est les
photos en conditions de faible
luminosité conditions nuit je tenais à
la main et comme vous n'avez aucune
stabilisation tout de suite c'est flou
la gelée posé sur un pied il ya beaucoup
de bruit c'est pas beau c'est
inexploitable
mais on arrive à deviner mais j'ai fait
la même chose avec la boîte du
smartphone posé sur un trépied mon foyer
il ya beaucoup de bruits c'est pas
terrible la photo nuit là dessus c'est
oublier également
on est ici sur un smartphone qu'il n'a
pas de certification ip68 en tout cas
s'il y en a une et bien c'est noté
absolument nulle part ça me paraît pas
absolument déconnant que sur ce
smartphone là vous n'ayez pas
certification ip68 simplement parce
qu'une certification ip68 ça coûte de
l'argent
20 25 dollars ne semble-t-il pour venir
faire certifier son smartphone j'imagine
que rémy soit vraiment casser les prix
être extrêmement agressif et du coup a
priori n'a pas cherché à aller là dessus
vous n'avez pas non plus de nfc donc
vous n'avez pas la possibilité d'avoir
du paiement dématérialisé pour le pass
navigo dématérialisée de la même manière
ça ne marchera pas et c'est un
smartphone qui sera 10 pour la vente à
partir du 7 avril prochain et existe
donc trois config 4 gigas
64 go de stockage à 229 euros 90 avec
une offre de reprise de 30 euros
vous avez également la confient des 428
à 269 euros 90 sans aucune offre de
reprise et 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage un peu moins de 300 euros 299
90 centimes sans offre de reprise
également un produit qui est dispo 100%
online vous mettre un lien dans la
description des que les liens seront
disponibles vous pouvez retrouver chez
cdiscount fnac darty ou rueducommerce ou
encore ldlc
alors que dire sur ce smartphone dans
cette gamme de prix aux alentours des
230 250 euros il ya quand même beaucoup
de monde
moi ce que je trouve bien s'éclate sur
emi nous fait une proposition
intéressante un smartphone qui ira bien
pour la performance
un petit peu standard quotidienne pour
jouer à des jeux on va pas chercher ce
qu'elle plus performants là dessus c'est
pas un smartphone qui est dédié pour le
gaming ont peu joué avec mais c'est pas
du tout son usage premier pour une
partie multimédia
le smartphone fait le boulot sur du
divertissement pour aller des films des
séries oublier encore pour aller jouer à
quelques jeux pas trop gourmands pour la
partie photo je trouve que la caméra
principale s'en sort vraiment bien c'est
là vous avez les meilleurs rendus que
c'est pour moi ce qui fonctionne le
mieux tout le reste je mets un petit peu
entre parenthèses donc si vous voulez
faire des photos de bonne qualité avec
le capteur principal sans chercher à
zoomer sans faire des faits sans rien là
vous aurez un rendu de qualité
c'est un smartphone qui n'est pas 5 g
mais une fois de plus sur un smartphone
milieu de gamme
ça me paraît aujourd'hui début 2020
assez normal et puis le design j'aime
bien quitter fait la comète n'est pas ce
que vous en pensez vous comment vous
trouvez le design de ce smartphone
dispose est bien le dos comme ça j'aime
bien toujours là la façon pour les
constructeurs devenir planquer leur
petite caméra il ya une caméra ils
savent qu'elle est là et il la cache
avec des petits fonds d'écran comme ça à
vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez en
banque au mans ça comment vous trouvez
sur risle mi6 est ce qu'il vous plaît
est ce qu'il pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu vous un
smartphone de rim
c'est le troisième coach test de remy je
vais tester le rythme ni deux il ya déjà
deux ans que ça devait être leur
première année art et demi et je l'avais
trouvé assez encourageantes dites moi
donc ce que vous en pensez vous en bas
en commentaire et quant à lyon se trouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler des cas les envoie des bisous à
demain ciao
[Musique]